All right, so it turns out there is going to
be an useful step here. Which is, we are
going to take advantage of the fact that minus epsilon
is greater than or equal to the natural law of
one minus epsilon; which maybe it's not so obvious
but if you plot it you could see that it's
true. If this is the epsilon axis then minus
epsilon looks like a straight line going down like that.
>> Sure it's got slope minus one.
>> Yep, and the log of one minus epsilon looks like this,
it starts off, they'll they're totally lined up at zero, epsilon zero.
>> Sure because one minus zero is one then absolute log of one is zero.
>> Exactly, and then what happens is it starts to fall away from it, the
slope is actually, I mean you could, you
can test this by taking the derivative of
it but the slope is if it's you
know it's monotonically I'm changing [LAUGH] so that
it falls away from the line and always
stays below it,okay, so if we believe that,
which, you know I'm going to just say calculus.
>> Well, you can kind of see that, right? Because
when epsilon is one, that would be the natural log of
zero and the only way you can raise e to
a power and get zero, is by having effectively, negative infinity.
>> Yeah, so right, by then, it's definitely below and but, it
stay below all along, I mean, because, just that is not enough, because.
>> Well, it has to stay below all along because
natural long is the natural log is a monotonic function.
Alright, so it can't like, get bigger and then
get smaller again, so, yeah, okay I buy that.
>> Good, alright, so if that's the
case,if we accept this line, then, it's also
going to be the case, that one minus epsilon to the m, is than or equal
e to the minus epsilon m, so why is that? So, if you multiply both
sides by m, and then take each of
the both sides, you get exactly this expression.
>> Sure. Alright?
So now that we've gotten that, we can use it
here in our derivation and rewrite that as, the size
of the hypothesis space times e to the minus epsilon
m. Alright that gives us another upper bound on the quantities
that we had before and this is much more convienent
to work with. The epsilon which had been kind of
trapped in the parentheses with the y minus now comes
up to the exponent where we can work with it better.
>> Sure.
>> Alright, so what this is is an upper bound
that the virgin space is not epsilon exhausted after m samples.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And that is what we would like delta to,
we would like delta to be a bound on that.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Right, so if delta is the,is the failure probability, essentially. So the
failure probability aught to be bigger than
or equal to this expression here, alright?
>> Okay.
>> So now, the last thing we need to do, is we can just
re-write this in terms of M.
>> Mm. So if we do that, let's see what happens. All right, when
we're done rewriting that what we find is the sample size M needs to
be at least as large as one over epsilon times the quantity the log
of the size of the hypothesis space plus the log of one over delta.
>> Okay and that is polynomial in one over epsilon,
one over delta, and the size of the hypothesis base.
>> Indeed!
>> Nice.
>> So that's pretty cool.
>> That is pretty cool.
>> So, right, it tells us if you
know the size of your hypothesis base, and you
know what your epsilon and delta targets are, you
know, sample a bunch, and then you'll be okay.
>> That's pretty good!